president trump traveled to utah today
where he dramatically cut back the size
of two national monuments
in that state when president trump
announced plans to scale back two
national monuments in utah
there was outcry from a lot of people
one company
in particular patagonia really is a
resistance brand they they embraced the
uh
the liberal resistance against president
donald trump
and really put themselves at the
forefront of that
movement in 2017 it sued the trump
administration
for sort of slashing the size of these
two national monuments in utah that were
kind of meccas for
for climbers it said at the time joining
the legal frackus was both
extraordinary and obvious so the
company's general counsel said it took
exactly
one email to the board to decide to
actually do this and the case is still
out
well i think the only thing this
administration understands is
lawsuits we're losing this planet and
we have an evil government and i'm not
going to stand back and just let evil
win
this year it got even more active it
changed its mission statement
to quote patagonia is in business to
save our home planet
and then it manufactured these little
tags on some of its clothes that
if you flip them up it says vote the
[ __ ] out
very implicit running up to the election
and it launched a digital tool to help
people find their polling place
and on that digital platform
it says vote the climate deniers out of
office again and again on loop
[Music]
this isn't the first time that taking a
stand has paid off for patagonia
the business which is now worth over a
billion dollars was built on it
i couldn't care less about making more
money
but by doing the right thing it always
ends up making me more money
so is this all a
strategy a sort of premeditated strategy
who knows i mean shonard's been very
vocal from the start and makes no bones
about he calls himself a dirtbag climber
and an accidental entrepreneur so i
don't think he's fudging this but what's
important
is that it's sort of a textbook marriage
of philanthropy
and profit
[Music]
if you want to understand the
entrepreneur study the juvenile
delinquent
because you know they're saying you know
this sucks
and i'm going to do it my own way
of course like every other teenage kid i
had no idea what i wanted to do with my
life
when i was 16 years old i took off and
drove across the country
went into the wind river range and
discovered mountains
[Music]
patagonia was born out of rock climber
yvonne schumannard's first business
chouinard equipment which made and sold
climbing supplies
yvonne schonard was a blacksmith in the
50s
and he started selling climbing gear out
of the back of his car
that was less harmful to rock faces this
is sort of
the origin story of the company it's
called itself the activist company
a activist company
six months out of the year ivan cenard
is a blacksmith
he makes mountain climbing gear the
other half of the year he climbs
in 1968 ivan chinard and four friends
including doug tompkins the late
founders of the north face brand
embarked on the ultimate road trip from
california where they were based to
patagonia in argentina the mountain's in
a good mood
dazzling sun calm air all day if this
weather holds they could be on the
summit within days
this trip became the documentary
about these friends who were hippies
in the 70s climbing in yosemite where
the sport became a lifestyle and how
these friends became pioneer of the
outdoor industry
moved from selling pitons to polyester
and in the seventies patagonia was born
in 1973 shoenard and his wife melinda
opened the very first patagonia store in
ventura california
where the company's headquarters
remained today
melinda schuennard was the driving force
behind many of the employee benefits
like on-site child care
that helped the company achieve an
impressive four percent employee
turnover rate
the retail and consumer product sector
average is more than triple that at 13
i do think that patagonia was a leader
one of the first corporations to
take into account you know the human
capital and make sure that
their staff all their employees were
cared for
in many ways not just wages but also
they just cared about their people and
knew that that's a good business model
patagonia began donating 10 percent of
its profits to grassroots organizations
in 1985.
this later became the one percent of
sales that schuynard labels an earth tax
i don't think it's philanthropy it's
it's rent for us
living on this planet while patagonia
was creating the blueprint of how to be
a socially conscious brand
it was also turning a profit it even
made inc magazine's list of the fastest
growing privately held companies
so every time the company makes a
decision to do something socially
environmentally active
it is met with success and that isn't
lost on shonard or
any of the other leaders of the company
the more money patagonia made
the more it gave away under its
philanthropic program
between 1989 and 1991 the payroll grew
by 40
but trouble was on the horizon i think
for 1991
we are looking at a recession the
question is how deep that recession is
going to be and how long will be in it
sales fell flat and the bank called in
the company's revolving loans
a company that prided itself on taking
care of its own
laid off 120 people roughly 20 percent
of its workforce
that was when we decided that we're
going to start doing things differently
we're going to start running the company
as if it's going to be here 100 years
[Music]
with a renewed sense of purpose
patagonia was ready for what it called
business unusual it started with the
costly move to recycled and organic
materials
before launching a clothing repair
service to discourage fast fashion
and patagonia's influence was growing
what was intended as chouinard's
philosophical handbook for employees
became an international blueprint for
sustainable business
printed in 10 languages
what's interesting to me is that all
this i hate the term on brand but it's
very on brand it really works
for the kind of company he's created it
works for the kind of employees
he's been able to recruit and retain it
all
is very seamless in terms of the
identity
of him and the company and and what it
means in the marketplace
so over time the company's mission and
its marketing
have become the same thing the
inflection point came in
2011 actually black friday patagonia
took out a huge ad in the new york times
that said don't buy this jacket and it
sort of
got into the nitty-gritty on you know
the carbon footprint and the water
footprint
that goes into you know a piece of
apparel like a parka
and at the time shonard said the best
jacket for our planet is one that
already exists
so the company at that time said it
needed to address the issue of
consumerism
which coming from a for-profit business
it's pretty hypocritical as the company
encouraged its customers to buy less
its annual sales increased by almost 40
percent
the stance of this is hypocritical was
loud and
constant talking about consumerism in a
critical light
while very much being a part of it
fast fashion is top on the list
of environmental destruction and not
just
destroying the environment but impacting
human health
they are in the fashion industry they're
a clothing retailer
and to come head-to-head with that
is courageous you're not only just
trying to
create a product that'll last but you're
also educating
an entire generation of people to
understand that whole ideology that
we don't need to change out our outfits
in 2014 rose mccarria was appointed as
ceo
during the next six years she grew
patagonia into a billion dollar company
while also scaling up its environmental
goals and bringing a more political
voice to its activism
ivan had this model where he was
basically
saying you can have a great business you
can make quality product
but you can also do the right thing
by the environment by your employees by
your community
and that to me was like the most
holistic vision
of business that i'd ever seen so right
now patagonia has a team of about 20
people
solely focused on activism and grants
and this all comes at a time in the past
decade
when consumers are paying much more
attention to
the social footprint of companies and
where they buy
their goods so what's happened is all
this is good business for patagonia in
the past 10 years
revenue and profit at the company
roughly quadrupled
it's private but estimates are it does
about a billion dollars in annual sales
which is sizable and that's part of the
reason why it's been such a
fortuitous cycle as it's ramped up its
activism and become more vocal on these
things
it's resonated with the market as the
company branched out into other areas
including a venture capital fund for
environmental causes
and sustainable food revenue reached a
new peak of over 1 billion dollars in
2017
but this was still small change compared
to fast fashion heavyweights like nike
who made 37 billion dollars that same
year
patagonia's conscience hasn't always
been reflected in its customer base
either
personalized vests have become the go-to
corporate uniform
and the expensive price tag has helped
the brand earn the nickname patagucci
it's expensive
stuff it's expensive apparel and that is
part of their calculus in terms of
the activism you know a lot of the more
sustainable
parts of the supply chain are there's a
premium for organic cotton or
sustainable down
the pataguchi label is is a symptom of
that
so patagonia products are very popular
of course with people who are active in
the outdoors but also with people who
are not
as active for instance you know people
in finance where the patagonia vest
go to the office and that's because of
the
image that the the brand projects and so
they have to leave with the fact
although they
you know preach for the environment and
want to stand for good
they're victims of their own success
patagonia set sales records in the first
three years
of the trump administration now in 2020
things have changed
as covert 19 brought the business world
to a halt and the american people voted
in a new administration
patagonia appointed brian gellich as ceo
as far as its ceo transition goes this
one's happening
quite strangely there's no real budget
for next year yet because of everything
that's going on and all the uncertainty
around that
patagonia's new focus is going to be on
forging
a relationship with the biden
administration
it should be a more close relationship
but gellert still has his guard up
during the obama administration they
didn't always
agree and he expects the same with biden
in the white house
[Music]
they plan to bring litigation wherever
needed against any government needed
about the issues that they care about
and that's climate change in the
[Music]
environment
[Music]
you